all right stephen adam here we are the
season finale that's right
for this episode we are doing something
crazy that we've never done before
two high-priced meals against each other
omo costa hotpot versus a
big meets baller board
[Music]
so the two restaurants in today's
episode were actually filmed for
two separate episodes originally but we
had to pause production due to coven 19
and we decided that
we'd like to still share these
restaurants with you and that they would
actually make
a great comparison in one video so we'll
be hosting this episode with me
and the highlander steven and adam at
home showing you these restaurants which
actually make
for a very interesting comparison you
may not think that a hot pot and a
meatboard
would make sense together however
they're both incredible stick
experiences
and both of them you sit down and don't
have to make any decisions
today on worth it we're going to be
trying two delicious
beef dishes at two drastic price points
and finding out which one is the most
worth it at its price
all right for the hot pot we are headed
to new york city
and where are we going today andrew
we're on our way to
a place called shabu-shabu mayuman we're
going to speak with
mayu and junkie and we're going to have
a very special
hot pot dinner it is omakase style
that's right we're getting some premium
beef and they're going to be doing the
dipping for us so
we literally cannot mess this up well
unless you can't transfer the food to
your mouth which in that case is on you
[Music]
here we are at shabu shabu mayuman thank
you for having us
what style of restaurant is shabu shabu
mayaman we offer like a umakase style
of the shabu shabu it's type of the
japanese hot part the way of the cooking
with the swishing the meat in the dashi
broth then dipping the sauce and
it it's like type of the tasting menu
and i've heard omokasi be referred to
sushi
is it common to see amukase for
shabu-shabu nah
really yeah so like only two locations
offered like a champion
even not in japan what does the menu
consist of so it comes three appetizers
first
after three appetizers beef and then
soba noodle
and dessert we just focus on paying
attention the detail
and also like the service for the guests
because the idea
from shabu is like a home cell i just
want customers enjoy the food and the
time because like i do everything so you
know you don't need to do anything so
this is your
shabu shabu place though yep the name of
the restaurant is named
after you means the end of the nickname
in japanese like steven moon
thank you for coming we're gonna start
sake it's operative thank you thank you
like an apple yeah it's so fruity wait i
thought you said the hot pot doesn't
come until later yeah small hop out so
it's a
little mushroom this is a ponzu we begin
i think we better because we got a lot
of
horses to get through i like that
we're starting off a meat-centric menu
with a very meaty substitute this is our
yuba you buy this biscuit
skin this is interesting she's dipping
tofu skin
inside liquid tofu skin why is that it
just makes it soft this is very
reminiscent of the tea ceremony taking
your time
really valuing every ingredient it's a
one bite a one bite
cheers i got the word to describe that
contrast so the hot pot has arrived but
we still have one more appetizer
dashi is a converse convoys are kind of
chewy
shrimp and caviar thank you
that was truly spectacular wow i gotta
say the the flavor of
garlic and caviar together i think is
not very common but it is
really delicious so you brought out the
next section of the menu
right this is our a5 miyazaki wagyu
ribeye which come from the japan
and that's the highest quality and then
we use wash yogurt
sugar is a crossbred of tajima beef and
angus beef from oregon state
and pogba why are you swishing the meat
like that
faster and eagerly to cook fast face is
a f5
miyazaki vagina with karajira sauce
harajiri is a soba dipping sauce
[Music]
so soft melting in the mouth it
absolutely did melt in my mouth yeah
when you're cooking in the broth what
are you looking out for
it's not that how long it is so i'm just
looking at
the color of the meat so wash your view
with the
one bite yes
the texture is fluffy when we do shabu
shabu we usually do like beef and pork
and some vegetable together so people
don't get bored
so i'm gonna make a hand roll now with
the miyazaki fish
thank you one bite or maybe two bites
the rice in the seaweed is a nice
reprieve it's a pork berry and
lettuce this reminds me of fosam korean
pork belly wrapped in lettuce with the
reversal and are we about to see tomato
sauce go on this oh that's the tomato
sauce wow really orange
it's snuck up on me yeah so all sauces
are homemade and we have
12 sauces one is tomato sauce and one is
vegan basil and balsamic soy sauce it's
kind of italian french style
but we use like some soy sauce so still
keeping like japanese flavors
[Music]
really good needed that we've now
entered anchovy and garlic based sauce
i feel like i just snuck out to a
different restaurant and like
ate something off somebody else's table
and then ran
into the strawberry strawberry place
wait that's a vegetarian wonton
mozzarella cheese inside there's a
wonton mocha cheese
and basil so is this a chinese inspired
italian chinese italian
could a cheese dish at shabu shabu-shabu
be better than all the meats
maybe what you do thank you
also it's a pork berry and spinach
sesame sauce and use peppers pizzas blue
cheese basil
balsamic soy sauce adam i'm gonna let
you have this one
he's stunned he's speechless he just
read it to eat himself
with wasabi that was that was the best
one
that's a tsukiyaki flavor and what is
sukiyaki the kind of another japanese
hot pot
oh so this is a play on another japanese
hot pot
in japan we bring the raw egg and then
eat
the egg gives an even softer sensation
in the mouth
can we just drink this egg yeah that's
really good so now we are moving to the
soba noodle so we
make soba noodle here and it's 100
buckwheat so it's
kind of difficult to make so the owner
used to be uh their soba
autism in japan he told us how to make
it so the broth is a remains super
mushroom
and this is a roast beef so is this a
traditional flavor for
soba noodles not really it's more like a
vietnamese fall style
oh right wow those are great
whoa is it possible to be comforted
from something you were already
comforted from you know when people say
i need a vacation for my vacation this
is like
comforting hot pot but then like
comforted from the comforting hot pot
yeah i like that that's great it's a tea
roasted green tea
it's a hojicha who is a roasted ricey
and then that bean on the side and the
soybean powder and buckwheat seed on the
top
[Music]
oh it's like when you're eating s'mores
and hot chocolate and you're by the fire
it's good i'm blown away overall by how
gentle of a dining experience this was
this is actually like
a fine dining steak experience but it
just happens to be cooked shabu-shabu
style
this is great thank you so much thank
you so much that was insane
i thought i knew what hot pot could be
but i was wrong and it was so much more
than
just a hot pot restaurant be fact this
is actually a worth it fact
was it fact including this episode there
are 66 episodes of worth it how many
episodes of worth it feature the hosts
eating beef
wait so did you just go to the library
and watch every moment of us eating
something
and count every single time we ate beef
yep respect
my number is 13. my number is 19. 34.
what does this make any sense how's that
possible
in the salad episode you guys eat two
steaks
[Music]
in the pie episode you go to pie and
burger and eat a burger
whose fault is that pancake episode you
eat a
beef and cheese i forgot about that
okay well that was an unsettling fact
adam but thank you for that
next up in this episode on beef we're
gonna be going to houston texas
to speak with an old friend of ours and
we've made it we're back in houston
that's right we're on our way
now to a place called georgia james
which is run by
chef chris shepherd now you may remember
a couple seasons back for our pie
episode when we were in houston we also
saw chris at his previous restaurant
underbelly chris has since
transformed underbelly into this new
restaurant georgia james so we're going
back to the same physical place
but for a wildly different experience
today we're getting something that is
called
the baller board so you don't know the
price of this when you order it
basically you ask for the baller board
and then they put
a combination of their best dishes on
this board this might actually be the
craziest thing
we've ever had on worth it the fact that
you don't know what it's going to cost
you just know that it's going to cost a
lot i love it
first of all thanks for having us back
it's good to see you georgie james is a
steakhouse
but what does that mean for you i wanted
to do a different style of steakhouse
basically what it would look like if you
came to my house on a sunday night how
would i do the sides
how would i cook a steak sides are a
little bit different it's going to be
cast iron seared steaks
so today we're having something called
the baller board yeah the baller board
is not part of your menu
no we don't talk about it a lot of
people are gonna know about it after
this yeah yeah
at underbelly you know we spent a lot of
time just curating menus for you if you
have a four top or six top or eight type
of people and they're just like we don't
really know we just want to put a bunch
of stuff together it's like okay let's
see what we're gonna do and then it
became the baller board it's not the
cheapest thing to do
they're definitely averages per person
but i mean if you're like you can't
outball me it's like
oh okay yeah we can actually it's always
like thoughtful and delicious you know
it's not just a bunch of stuff thrown on
the plate it takes four to ride
minimum of four people even if you're
three it's still gonna be food for four
you really don't get a choice in
anything it's a really good way to eat
so you're probably gonna get things that
you may or may not have tried and
thought you wanted but you didn't so
coming in
i don't know what it's gonna cost at the
end nope is there a range typically
oh we basically just cost like whatever
it is on the board so it's
clearly documented i'm excited greg
peters who's the chef here and then matt
coburn who is the sous chef they're
going to put everything together for you
so you guys are gonna be making the
baller board today yes sir
absolutely how do you decide what goes
on this board so nightly that falls
on either one of us to both of us
nothing is off the table
there's steak plenty of seafood chicken
lamb part of the
mystique of the baller board is that
there are some items on there that are
not going to be on the menu
if we feel like buying things like foie
gras having caviar in the building
sometimes things like that get purchased
only for baller boards so pretty much
every steak that leaves this kitchen is
seared in a cast iron pan
nice sear nice crust restaurants use
broilers or grills
that steak is going to leech moisture
and blood and juices
on a grill or broiler all that is
getting lost but when we're cooking in a
cast iron pan
all it's staying in the pan so we're
essentially building flavor every other
dish kind of gets put on hold for that
three and a half minute plate up one
guy's throwing sides
doing a swoosh of whipped potatoes i'm
slicing steaks on the back pass some
guys coming around with crab legs it's
a well-oiled machine that just all comes
together
it's going a long way on this show in
some ways we've gone nowhere
oh my all right gang how are we doing
i'm not
i'm not sure it's like when when fear
takes away your appetite right
just like this i'm here to give you a
little rundown first up though we have
some alaskan
king crab leg cream collard greens whole
roasted snapper fillet
maybe on the creole seasoning missed it
on the butter right
here next to that we have some smashed
fried new potatoes and then on top of
that we have about our 20-ounce 44 farms
tenderloin topped out with a nice piece
of seared
foie gras and some caviar some smoked
pork and topped with a little bit of a
samjong sauce so kind of a korean
influence on the center of the board is
our most unique steak here in house
about a 95 day dry age long bone rib eye
brown butter roasted mushrooms
loaded mashed potatoes right here is our
wagyu zabuton we have some roasted
cauliflower
topped with a tomato curry that about
covers it no right or wrong way to
attack it dig in and enjoy yourselves
thank you so much
amazing thank you all thank you i want
to talk about what we just
witnessed which i would possibly say is
the greatest
show i've ever seen in a kitchen i
legitimately
forgot that there was a fish on this
board yeah because i can't even see
the fish on this board how about we
start with that choice
rare i like where you're going what's
that let's go wow
i'm wasting no more time cheers
oh my god the crust is so
insane let's compare the wagyu now okay
to
the angus rib eye oh whoa
oh look at that
this is super fun let's get this
tenderloin yeah let's go to the
tenderloin do you want to smear the foie
gras
you know what this is worth it baby this
is hedonism
defined okay
tastes like if a cinnabon was meat
i just had a brilliant idea here's what
we do potato do you know what i'm gonna
go next
caviar yeah oh you're a crazy person
we once ate a taco that was only this
and that was the whole episode
no that is that is so true this wins it
like
of any dish we've ever had this is the
most worth it-esque
dish i want some of the collard greens
because it looks like
dip you know what actually because of
that i'm gonna dip wag you
into the collard greens i think david
chang would be proud
i can't my i can't handle it my mouth
i'm just okay i'm getting some
pork now oh do you want to just share
that
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh wow oh god
it's like i suspected there's a whole
ham on this board
this board is going ham let's go let's
go crab leg
how's that meat luge
[Music]
oh my god oh my god what do we forget i
forgot about the fish
for a second time fish let's just get
the fish
all right let's get the fish over here
it's so good oh tender and smoky this is
what the baller board is all about not
caring
what you're eating but it's delicious
and somebody else had to care for you
you can't do that in literally any other
profession
you don't go to a car dealership and
you're like baller board in my car
all aboard me i do for one second i want
to see something serious
i think the distinction to make here
that's very important for the audience a
lot of you guys say that you know
oh those restaurants are just cheating
because you know they add caviar truffle
yada yada this restaurant did every
single aspect of this board
excellently yeah and that i think is
what makes this
so worth it oh i haven't caught bar yet
i think there's
four things on this board i haven't even
eaten yet
you know me i end every meal with good
old
bone meat look at this you're eating a
big bone i mean the crab like this is
the best piece of meat on the board
okay this is clearly too much food
so andrew we've come here to the end
what was your favorite
bite i'm gonna go with maybe what'll be
a little bit more of an
unsung hero and i'm gonna go with the
lettuce bite at
shabu-shabu mayuman the way that a
bundle
of hot lettuce can transport broth to
your mouth
is really unique and i think quite
delicious all right so for me
it was also at shabu-shabu mayuma and it
was the yuba
uni oh my god i have a photo here of it
it's one of those things where i wish i
could eat my phone
andrew which beef experience to you
what's the most worth it at its given
price point
my honest answer is shabu shabu mayaman
like you're getting some of the best
food presented in the best way
but it's also very relaxed and intimate
you know i could make arguments for both
very easily if you have four people go
with you to shop and shop in my iman the
prices
are pretty similar we got some stuff at
georgia james that really
made our experience a quite a bit more
expensive than
it could have been i think i gotta say
the meat board
really cause that meal it would feed six
to eight people i believe and it would
be
just the most grand old time with all
that food in front of you
adam how about you george's james really
and that does it for another season of
worth it giving all the recent news and
events
we've taken for granted is eating at
restaurants and so i hope that everybody
out there
stay safe but also support your local
restaurants if you can and also thank
you to
all the people involved making this show
both in front and behind the camera see
you next time
[Music]
you